[Music]
in best first date news the bitter sting
[Music]
submitted by yummy for my tummy you so
hungry
cinder is sending a couple on their
first date to Hawaii
the first date three years after they
matched I'm guessing all so they've been
talking for three years but they never
met oh my god what a bunch of [ __ ]
lovely people because because that's
dedication
cuz I'm absolutely not you know they
just texted for three years straight and
never went on a date I would I'm
guessing they snapchatted in my you know
name of my body because I need that much
immediately I thought that's what tuna
was for the tendon was for [ __ ] oh
yeah I thought the only match the mr.
cool and the local right local what
sounds like Tinder's trying to change
their image
no tunics for [ __ ] no I think that
they're trying to change the image now
right how they trying to change it this
is the stigma okay tinder is for people
who want to lose relationships and maybe
little boo suppose here in there and a
little ding ding right and then you have
coffee meets bagel where the people
aren't as attractive but their hearts
are this big oh that's what coffee meets
bagel is but I like big hearts and big
butts here's my question
I thought tinder only uses local people
how do they match and not meet for three
years cuz they're lazy to leave you love
oh my god is like frickin they're like
20 miles away and they just or maybe
they're like taking a really slow or
they're shy or they spelled out
everything instead of point what's your
favorite color we go what4s what is the
rate ain't no real reason tip what's the
real reason all those what yeah I
thought you were gonna say white what's
your favorite color what like it was
going to what's the real reason why now
the real reason is because when I first
initially matched
Josh 20 to 22 year olds Josh sent a
message over the 21 year old
she'll tender saying hi Michelle you
want to [ __ ] and then ah it took
quite some time for him to get back to
him and I'll read to you guys their
conversations over it ball here's Josh
oh he was like this is my fish I catch
this fish about the seniors at the
University really good I'll tame it when
they were 20 to 21 or they met when they
were 20 to 21 or Eric currently 20 to
tweens older they match while they were
in the same College and they were close
to each other yeah wait should your
college users oh my god it could just
walk to the library this is me his
library library like branch because
library hey they're like not
unattractive people book all the time
library why are they just waiting yeah
so then Josh tweeted vision difficult
dish she has mimosa breakfast so Josh
tweeted this out it says oh [ __ ] okay is
that hahaha
one day I'm going to meet this girl and
it's going to be epic look at the base
of our tinder texts and solar screen
shot and so the first one says new
management Michelle on September 20th
2014 how naughty Michelle on November
28th 2014 she says hey my phone died and
then we'll pick it up what September to
November yeah and then so on that st. or
the next day November 29th 2014
Josh wrote Wow you found that pretty
fast it usually takes me about five
months to find my charger and then on
November 29th same day she writes yeah I
just wanted to make sure it was fully
charged 0 to 100 real slow another one
and that was dad right
none January 19 2015 so that's two
months later almost hey what sorry was
in the shower February 13 2015 kay just
saw this message sorry I was in class he
writes back on May 18th 2015
sorry Michelle I have made a horrible
first impression I really caught up with
finals oh my god yeah it really paid off
fail 28th 2015 she said hi
I really do apologize for sorry for
three years just now getting back to you
I've just had a really busy week on
October 10 2016 he writes Michelle I
don't want you to think I'm rude
midterms are coming up and it's been
really hard to keep up with it all it's
almost like an Android Jojo and then he
writes back
February 22nd 2017 hey Josh just wanted
to get back to you really quick
Presidents Day had me really swamped you
know how I get when you're celebrating
George Washington's birthday whoo busy
busy yeah and then so he ends up
tweeting that conversation and tinder
it's got a hold of it organic synthesis
why did you [ __ ] it already [ __ ]
turtle ass [ __ ] some dude mad it's
time you got together in real life you
have 24 hours to decide the city you
want to have your first date in and
we'll send you there wow that's pretty
dope and they said Oahu
so then he responds after a long debate
over your unbelievably unbelievably
generous offer our dream first dates
would be in Hawaii meet you in Maui and
then he asked her her twitter handle
ginger says Aloha we're sending you to
Maui but you can't take two years to
pack your bags oh whoa my legs are
getting sent to now that's really dumb
right can I just let me ask the question
are they going to be on the same flight
together because like that's interested
in the same area so they go on the same
flight so they already on the date and
when they land there are they going to
book the same hotel
I know Mike and everything is all
separate yeah because if everything is
separate really boring it really does
take you this long just think of
something I'm just saying that this
story and their conversation is one of
them boring is [ __ ] things I've ever
heard
[ __ ] and they're gonna give men a D
in their [ __ ] face please now I agree
when I saw this was viral like really
dude that seriously was three years of
I'm so sorry I'm a planner
kind of seems like you know they started
this conversation and then somebody the
other person started dating somebody and
when they finally broke up them they're
like oh I'm gonna text this guy again
and then he was already dating
somebody's all chaotic exactly that I
think they were involved in other
relationships so they're kind of like
hey are you still interested so you are
okay but a book is other person right
now but it was a good it was a queue
ongoing joke I agree it's [ __ ] boring
and like it was stupid and I also agree
with your theory I think the same thing
happened but they kept the joke going
and I thought that was cool I don't want
to be sent to Maui
he says yourself every year I don't want
to do it on my dime it's so much better
when you think what about the lingerie
back to each other because Michelle is
Danish she would delete the app and then
reread a shame though halter she she was
like back and forth with getting back to
him so neither of them is Aleta where
she was another she broke up with her
love of her life so she her bears like
girl watch a girl tender you'll find
somebody better okay I'll try but I'm
like that kind of girl though and she
said oh he killed and then her Berber
I'll miss you come in you too I'm going
to delete tinder near later same [ __ ]
breaks up with her I gotta just try ten
to one more time oh it's that guy again
she's so funny so you can only text each
other if you are the bat because that's
that's what I wanted yeah I wanted to
hear the Juicy Juice like that
that's what happened but all I hear was
hey story mister do you know how it goes
it's just like an ongoing joke that
other than wanted to be the first to
break you can't text people off of
tinder you can't get their numbers yeah
if you get their number but they never
reached that point they were just
constantly like hey sorry hey sorry they
must have really long form you know he
really wanted to see you because he's
doing who tweeted that out hoping for
something to happen yeah so they're
gonna get married on there like 80 years
old yeah everyone is like please guys
get married the story so thoughtful
better not all over her because that's
just three years in the making you
better not leave that hotel they better
stay in that hotel that won't you stink
right with a [ __ ] clearly
uh he needs to not like 5 gallons in
exactly 3 years worth a cup yeah and she
better scream until the [ __ ] window
shatter he is a beautiful place I wonder
where they're going to take them I know
I wanted to I like how long yeah here
you do it brother so yeah yeah like
tinder hasn't really seni which hotel
wait have they done it yet have they
gone no this is just recent are they
going to snorkel we should all go there
we should ah you got it she wants to do
almost say something quick I don't know
if I would want to go on a first date to
some [ __ ] [ __ ] stuff sure I would
it's [ __ ] Maui though man I guess I
would like a chance if I didn't like I
ditch her all day and be like I'm going
smart maybe they are doing that maybe
they go there like I sweet so you have
someone right yeah I got someone -
aren't we gonna split Marta the real
like significant other can just get
there on their own and they split the
fare
two for the price of one then and
they're gonna [ __ ] each other that's a
foursome
what oh what an awesome says Maui orgy
the girl and girl the gun guy that's man
rich a mess reckless
yeah well the word on not that part
nasty I'm just thinking the orgy is
nasty
it's going to smell like pacifist and
citrus look this is all about work okay
so that guy is but [ __ ] the guy and
his wiener is in the girls [ __ ] but
there's one lonely girl Joe needs a
snapchat filter that has a geek glasses
in all this about Instagram is it no
Instagram destroy them on that I want to
hear an update I got to hear that either
they [ __ ] hated each other's guts and
the dudes softer the mouth or something
I'm saying I'm saying I'm it the girl
stalks him in the mouth
oh no equality the guy stopped serving
fries they both gave us a fight
exactly I want to see them Duke it out
and show they both get married it fall
in love and let me break up or they got
to get together she's drinking mimosa on
the few things that are gonna happen one
of those seasons he's catching a tuna
he is moving this is really on I want to
see this I want to see them fight for
some reason I don't know why I want is
because you need some service Michelle I
hear there's no oh exactly so boring I
want me to see something like yeah I
wish they're like I can't wait to [ __ ]
your brains out can't wait to blow your
bit and then it's like I can't I don't
have enough money or like something like
my mother won't let me out I'm sure I'm
21
you know something like some give me a
[ __ ] what's that Rapunzel girl get
long hair [ __ ] give me that story we've
seen the Rapunzel doesn't move give me
that one she's violated I can't because
my mama says I can't go out goes girl I
need a funky listen right now or else
I'm gonna die
thank you hi I know me too why don't you
climb in my [ __ ] hair follicles and
then rips are bald and [ __ ] you know
what we're gonna [ __ ] buy the wig but
guaranteed and we're going to send you
to Hawaii
you guys can finally [ __ ] one of all my
positive people I want to hear your
thoughts put it in the comments below
because if you're negative shut the hell
up and go drink some raid please but if
you're very positive leave it in the
comments below
but the last video over here
[Music]